hugo planea comprar dos paquetes de
tarjetas de béisbol hasta que encuentre
la tarjeta de su jugador favorito pero
el dinero que tiene solo le alcanza para
comprar un máximo de cuatro paquetes
supón que cada paquete tiene una
probabilidad de 0.2 de contener la
tarjeta que hugo quiere sea la variable
aleatoria x el número de paquetes que
compra hugo a continuación se muestra la
distribución de probabilidad para x
parece que hay una probabilidad de 0.2
de que compra un paquete lo cual tiene
sentido porque nos dicen que hay una
probabilidad de 0.2 de que la tarjeta
que busca esté en un paquete de ser así
el ya no compraría más paquetes cuál es
la probabilidad de que compre dos
paquetes a quien nos dicen que es 0.16 y
tiene sentido porque hay una
probabilidad de 0.8 de que él no
encuentre la tarjeta que busca en el
primer paquete y hay otra probabilidad
de 0.2 de que encuentre la tarjeta que
busca en ese otro paquete 0.8 x 0.2 es
igual a 0.16
pero no nos piden que lo calculamos ya
nos dan los datos la probabilidad de que
compre tres paquetes es cero punto 128 y
no sabemos cuál es la probabilidad de
que compre cuatro paquetes esta es la
distribución de probabilidad discreta
completa ya que hugo no puede comprar
más de cuatro paquetes aún cuando no
encuentre la tarjeta que él quiere en el
cuarto paquete ya no puede comprar más
podemos calcular esta incógnita al
darnos cuenta de que la suma de todas
estas probabilidades tiene que ser igual
a 1
respondamos lo que nos piden encuentra
la probabilidad indicada cuál es la
probabilidad de que x sea mayor o igual
que 2 recuerden que x es el número de
paquetes que compra hugo los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
calcular esto por su cuenta
veamos los escenarios que nos interesan
la probabilidad de que nuestra variable
discreta x sea mayor o igual que 2 son
estos tres escenarios
cuál es su probabilidad combinada quizá
piensen que primero debemos calcular
cuál es esta probabilidad pero
y sabemos que la suma de todas tiene que
ser igual a 100 por ciento este es 0.2 y
si éste es 0.2 entonces las otras
probabilidades combinadas deben ser
iguales a 0.8 0.8 0.2 es igual a 1 o al
100% así de rápido sabemos que esta
probabilidad es igual a 0.8 si
quisiéramos conocer la probabilidad para
el cuarto tenemos que completar la suma
para que el total sea igual a 1 así que
la probabilidad de que tengamos
exactamente 4 es 1 menos 0.2 menos 0.16
menos 0 punto 128.8 menos puntos 16
menos punto 128 y nos da igual a cero
punto 512
y quizá piensen que esta es una
probabilidad muy alta hay una
probabilidad mayor al 50% de que hugo
tenga que comprar 4 paquetes y recuerden
que no puede comprar más de cuatro
paquetes aun cuando en el cuarto paquete
no encuentre la tarjeta que busca se
tiene que detener ahí es por eso que hay
una gran probabilidad de que tenga que
comprar los cuatro paquetes hay una
probabilidad menor al 50% de que
encuentre la tarjeta que busca antes de
este punto